a lockdown lifted at a local high school
after a gun was found on campus it
happened at west preparatory academy
which is not too far from west lake mead
and mlk that's where we find joe muller
tonight live with the latest details joe
now the lockdown happened earlier this
morning and after it was lifted students
resumed class like normal now parents
say they're pretty frustrated that a gun
actually got on the campus here and now
they want more to be done
two juveniles were arrested on the west
preparatory academy campus after a gun
was found according to a letter from the
principal during the search for that gun
the school was on lockdown no threats
were made against the school parents did
not know what was happening they say
they did not get an update until a
letter from the principal after the
issue was resolved one parent who did
not want to go on camera says from
fights to guns there have been too many
problems it's a bogus message we get
that everything is under control and at
the end of the day nothing is really
under control the kids don't know what
even is going on in these schools the
letter from the principal also pushed
parents to discuss reporting issues that
could be of a concern
now back out here live we just talked to
one student who says he didn't not even
know anything was going on while he was
in class now parents say they need
things like metal detectors or even more
security on campus to help keep the kids
safe reporting live joe muller live
local now